how are you doing today sir good thank
you so I guess I have to I guess my
first thing is the superhero genre like
the comic book movie has become the most
popular thing around the world what do
you think it is about the genre that
appeals to so many people it's the
fantasy isn't it that probably created
those comics in the first place the
world was a war in 1939 1940 when Shazam
was first written and what we needed
were heroes to help us out of the
problems and I think we're going through
very difficult times in the world today
so the kind of fantasy of being able to
solve all of our problems is a really
rich one you have a badass outfit in the
movie what is the secret to coming up
with and working with a costume designer
to create the badass villain costume
well I think in this particular instance
what's the best thing about Zach's
costume is Shazam is it's slightly
larger than life it's slightly redder
you know the little gold cuffs the cape
you know all of that is kind of a
fourteen-year-old boys version of what a
superhero should be so I felt the
Savannah should wear what a
fourteen-year-old boys version of a bad
guy should be and that's exactly what
they came up with you know the little
gray and the little black sunglasses
that were very mysterious and slightly
creepy and that fantastic black leather
cloak that floats beautifully in the
wind when you're terrorizing children of
course um hypothetically you wouldn't
have borrowed that coat from set would
you uh well no I didn't because you know
I think it's one thing wearing it in the
movie it's another thing walking down
the Kings Road in London I think it's a
very different kind of fish right I
still would have borrowed one would you
100 say one of the things that I act
first of all I love the movie it's so
well done but one of the things that
actually surprised me was what you were
allowed to get away with in that
boardroom like I I was a little bit like
surprised in terms of what your
character does talk a little bit about
the fact that this movie that you've got
to show a real dark side yeah it doesn't
shy away from a kind of really nasty
sort of feel and I think that's partly
David Sandberg horror background you
know he knows how to make something
really creepy and a bit scary but also
we always decided that and we always
wanted Savannah to be a proper nemesis
I mean if you don't have that jeopardy
the hero isn't in danger because your
bad guy is really dangerous where's the
drama so to have a scene like that at
the beginning of the movie is really
fantastic because it just makes
everybody realize that Savannah is
really somebody to be reckoned with I am
incredibly looking forward to the Dark
Crystal and I wanted to know if you
could tease people about what your
you're doing isn't it yeah and what can
you tease people about it I think it's
gonna be really fascinating I mean when
I go in to do one again to do the voice
and I see how Luna Terry is shot
everything first you're kind of aware
that it's it's puppets it's a weird
world but if what was amazing to me was
how quickly you just accept what you're
seeing and how brilliant the story is it
really pulls you in I think it's gonna
be pretty amazing is it and I because I
don't know it's 30-minute episodes it's
an hour do you know I don't actually
know I know it's ten episodes they've
done surface I don't know how long they
are but bizarrely I play Taryn
edgington's father so with full circle
we're back together again right they're
completely oh I already got a go but a
lasting real first oh you did temple or
you're filming come play yes can you
tease people about that that's a series
that we've done for Sky back in the UK
that is about a surgeon trying to save
his dying wife who makes a number of
very odd choices and finds himself in a
very strange place from the world that
he originally lived any kind of crosses
the Rubicon and ethically and morally
you ask questions of him congratulations
on this movie gotta go but suceeded
great
you